he just tricked
[Music]
oh that he's hilarious he knows he knows
who he's up
against Magnus shaking his head there
maybe he thinks he had something even
better this is still good but he needs
to be accurate now because his his
Advantage is no longer longterm there's
a piece that's dropped off the board uh
okay I didn't even spot that Nakamura
just left his Bishop hanging oh wow he
lost a bishop for free he forgot to
defend it it's a a blunder and not even
a complicated one Magnus is taking a
free Bishop come on it's the last game
potentially of the tour you know let's
have some fun I'm gonna I'm just going
to wheel it out you know I've got he's
got obviously major fan club I'm gonna
I'm gonna get them something to talk
about and I'm going to play Queen H5
what the
[Music]
hell
gosh Levy is struggling with this he's
down to 13 seconds queen king H King H I
love this this is amazing defense H6
Levy just has to ignore this he's
overthinking it yeah he's nervous of the
reputation he understands that there's
these constant stalemate ideas Queen F6
and now there's no stalemate that's
really nicely dunk take on F seven and
that's look at
Levy L is hilarious he knows he knows
who he's up against Queen T Bishop wins
Magnus wins the game Wesley resigns
immediately Wesley so just gives up
Magnus Carlson this was a dramatic game
he ends up winning this game and look at
him he looks shocked yeah I think he's
shocked about his own blunder earlier
but also shocked that now he's smiling
here we have it usually we would be
going crazy for this pairing but knowing
that all this craziness is happening
with the qualific
ation it's it's kind of what and Magus
goes K don't don't do this don't do this
laughes and King E7 King E7 finally and
now King E2 draw King E2 King E7 draw or
what at Peter he cannot he can't
stop both it's it's I have to say it's
kind of nice to see these two players
having a laugh like this we've seen them
fight it out and we've seen them uh who
can forget the Carlson Chester final
we've seen some epic battles between the
two this one is just it's just a joke
Carlson meanwhile smiling because he
knows he's he's tricked dub off he's
surprised him is that why why we're
seeing Magnus Carlson with a smile a
grin on his face there he just tricked
oh why is Magnus Carlson having a huge
laugh here David I mean unless he's
listening to us I'm not sure Ka remember
he laughed the other day and we asked
him and he couldn't remember why he was
laughing well this is a bigger laugh
this is the reason why you can see uh
you know he's turning Dub's philosophy
against himself do you remember du duor
famously said when my pieces are
attacked I Counterattack and uh here it
goes so far wincent is being very fast
but yeah mnus will obviously not
hesitate to uh to flag here oh okay not
needed because vincon somehow Prem moved
of his Rooks
away that was a nice and lost on time
yeah so yeah Winston managed to actually
lose this position on the board somehow
because Rook G6 he could have if he saw
that Rook G6 was played he could have
taken on6 and taken on A5 and at least
guarantee a draw but instead he pre
moved all of these moves and uh
yeah
with this uh with this nice porn chain
and uh yeah still some chances Magnus
looks like he's loving life though
smiling to
himself yeah that's he's looking quite
amused and happy with what's happening I
wonder what's going on there yeah just
uh happy with life yeah happy yeah with
something clearly what's happening
loving the air out there in Canada I
have no idea but of course he's happy
about the match result thus far he's up
a full point and with black he seems to
have no problems out of the opening
there hikaro Nakamura on the clock David
was just mentioning we could see a
Connect Four of those pawns and hiar
actually brings his KN all the way back
so Magnus has had no struggles against a
car over the board he's maybe had a
worse position for two move total in all
the games they played here in the air
things master so why not smile he should
be happy and now we go PA again I think
oh
dear
well and pH again yeah okay okay
okay let's go
[Laughter]
PA well it's not yet losing yeah so you
know those pun moves still
work uh by Nakamura and so we you know
we had some decisive games but the games
that even are drawn have been so back
and forth so full of energy and fun and
there was a funny the reason I was
smiling and looked over is because you
missed it that he almost grabbed a piece
and then stopped and smiled like he
forgot his line it was actually really
funny he was he he did one of these and
then went oh and then like smiled so
whatever he did he was like thank God I
didn't touch that Rook audy's going to
strike back wow what a turnaround this
is with the black pieces David which
means he goes into the final round with
white but there's still work to be done
it's not over till it's over against the
world champion but this game is over
because Magnus just resigned arent he
wins and we have a level match wow that
is huge AR generary he strikes backs he
ties the match before the fourth and
final rapid game Magnus Carlson loses
his first game of the Champions chest or
[Music]
season